foreign
[Music]
this was definitely a part of the degree
that I was very interested in pursuing
one of the most important parts of the
education just understanding that what
you're drawing and what you're looking
at on a plan how that's actually
physically represented on site is it
extremely important
[Music]
I've been here for like seven or so
years and I've seen these houses pop up
in different communities and sort of
seeing how they've changed hands and and
seen you know residents living in them
for for years on end you know it it does
make you sort of feel a little bit more
connected to communities throughout New
Haven
what is fundamental to architecture with
shelter and so when we're talking about
serving a population who has experienced
vulnerabilities of perhaps not having
shelter it really foregrounds the
importance of making spaces that are
both
areas of Refuge but also areas of
aspiration so it really grounds
architecture as a service to people
[Music]
foreign